come on sweetie you're okay
dramatic body camera footage shows a
young girl's rescue after she was
abducted by her father who does not have
custody
oh
well we're here to help you okay babe
it happened on January 10th in Ohio dash
camera video from the Ohio State Patrol
shows officers chasing a silver Ford
Taurus with Michigan plates eventually
the car pulls over and officers yell to
the driver are you alone
are you alone in the car
that's right
you
right okay all right the driver later
identified as Eric nardolini says his
daughter is in the back seat officers
instruct him to throw his keys out of
the window and then proceed to arrest
him driver throw the keys out the window
throw the keys out the window
with your hand open the door nardolini's
daughter was identified as four-year-old
Liliana who was missing from her home in
Michigan come on sweetie you're okay
come on
sweetie you're okay
okay you're okay sweetie you're okay
after an officer rescues Liliana from
the back seat she can be heard saying
she was scared during the chase after
that the officer tells her she is safe
oh well we're here to help you okay babe
yeah we're gonna we're gonna get your
mom over here we're gonna we're gonna
take care of you okay okay all right
investigators say nardolini had no legal
right to take his daughter after being
ordered by the court to turn Liliana
over to her mother reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie